here to discuss the impeachment trial is
Kevin surly chief Washington
correspondent for Bloomberg News Kevin
good morning welcome lay out what's
gonna happen today and then heading into
really nice so this morning is the first
opportunity for the president's legal
team to make their case after they had
the 24 hour marathon by the impeachment
prosecutors the Democrats to make their
case now president's not too happy about
this simply because of the timing they
would like to see some prime time action
and that's why when I'm hearing from my
sources is that ultimately they're gonna
save a little bit of the action for
early next week
to make their to really make some other
more okay so how is this new audio
recording factoring in its it is
factoring in in the sense that you know
we were talking a little bit this about
this before I got on air is that it
matters to the public the expectation
it's been it's been baked in that
Republicans Senate Republicans will not
vote to impeach or to convict President
Trump but said the public the
Republicans now need to answer to that
to this new type of evidence it's almost
like there are two trials there is the
one that's going on a Senate and then
it's the court of public opinion at
least in mentioning that recording will
we see new witnesses and will we see new
evidence coming forward any indication
well I'm struck by the the notion that
this conversation over witnesses is
still being had my source is connected
to Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell would indicate that this they
would like to see this trial move
efficiently and over the next week and a
half
that said Republican sources tell me why
were all why wasn't all of this decided
in the house side now Democrats are
pushing they are making a transparency
argument either way when you take a step
back here February fourth mark your
calendar the president's State of the
Union address that's the working
timetable from when the president wants
to have this does the question of
witnesses all come down potentially to
Lamar Alexander who is close to
McConnell of course because right now
you have Collins Murkowski and Romney
all open to witnesses so does that then
all come down to Lamar Alexander yes yes
point in a way and and in essence I
would also suggest that even being open
to witnesses is not saying there has to
be witnesses so there's this Washington
wiggle room that candidly inside the
beltway we're all used to at this point
there was this notion or implication by
the Democrats that Rudy that President
Trump was influenced by Rudy
Giuliani who is therefore some kind of I
guess Lackey
so to speak President Putin in Russia I
mean that has floated to to the surface
year in a way that I could frankly had
not heard before no I spent the week
traveling with Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo through Latin America as well as
Europe and I asked him in an interview I
point-blank about this notion that
Democrats have raised that there's a
shadow foreign policy or a shadow State
Department and he was adamant that there
is not Jeff mentioned this idea of if
they can get enough Republicans we could
possibly see the witnesses what right
now has been the strongest argument that
the Democrats have made that we've seen
over the last 24 hours which may lead to
this their argument is what took so long
and why are we here what if you had all
of these months in terms of
investigations and in the house and so
ultimately that they feel that this it's
their job now to decide whether or not
to convicted that said they had the
polling suggests especially in
battleground states that that voters
independent voters especially want to
see lawmakers taking this trial
seriously quote vote against the
president and your head will be on a
pike which was from a CBS reports all
the great seems to be playing a role
right now especially as we heard things
wrapping up from the Democrats precisely
now when that when Adam Schiff who was
the chairman of the House Intelligence
Committee read that in the last 24 hours
on the floor during that there were
audible are gasps and I roles to some
extent and Republican senators saying
that they were not told that however it
again and that's excellent reporting
speaks to the notion of the public trial
that you and I were just talking about
they want to see lawmakers on both sides
taking this seriously
yes or no would it have any difference
will it make any difference which on the
overall vote vote you know look III
think I would be based upon my reporting
and who I talk to I know I'm not saying
yes or no I I would be surprised if
ultimately this trial drags out for more
than your being on we rarely get on yes
sir
we never I think it matters what they
think thank you thank you